the government in Bangladesh is
threatening to send tens of thousands of
refugees to a remote island by force
despite warnings from environmentalists
and rights groups accommodation on the
island abbis and char has been specially
constructed for the refugees the
government says it will offer a new
start for the reinjure but the low-lying
island in the bay of bengal is
vulnerable to erosion and flooding and
critics have condemned the plan
our correspondent Naomi Conrad was
granted access to the site in the
world's largest refugee camp in southern
Bangladesh fear is rife two years ago
the government welcomed the influx of
Ranga fleeing Myanmar today it is
planning to send tens of thousands of
them to an island in an area prone to
cyclones we don't want to go to bath and
char because it gets flooded and then
people will die our children will be
drowned for them it's another trap where
they'll lose their lives if we go there
we'll die help us to stay here we lost
our parents and came here to save our
lives don't send us to pass on Chau just
kill us here no Western journalists have
been granted access to the island until
now DW was taken to bazan char by
Bangladesh Navy which is overseeing the
construction works throughout our stay
we were accompanied by naval officers
they took us three hours to reach Bazin
char on a naval ship the sea was choppy
but relatively calm for this time of the
year
what is the longest period that you
think chips might not be able to reach
the island and didn't work really bad
weather conditions if the cyclonic storm
warning that maybe one or two days or
three days maximum not more than that
and we have no worker we have for the
Navy ship we have never stopped nobody
will be evacuated from this island that
is because the Navy says they have built
sufficient protection against floods and
erosion including a three meter high
embankment inside their space for
100,000 row hangers housed in clusters
of identical shelters human rights
organizations fear that refugees may be
contained on the remote island for years
sometimes this this island is described
as a jail does that offend you
yes the question is the people who makes
comment like floating island unsafe
island yes they don't understand the
island they didn't see the island and
they don't know about the hot facility
we are providing the islands 120 cyclone
shelters can be used as hospitals
primary schools and community centers to
provide security there will be police
posts and cameras monitoring the island
we will provide something to the RO
hangar they will remember it for their
life and is in the crisis we help them
if they come here it is paradise for
them is the no doubt about them from
what we've seen conditions here do seem
to be better than in [ __ ] bizarre but
questions remain around what daily life
might be like will there be secondary
education for young people what will
they do all day can the refugees earn
their own living and will they be able
to leave the island without a special
permit and of course what happens here
when a cyclone hits
bazan Shah didn't exist 20 years ago
islands in the Bay of Bengal are formed
by sediments and make up an
ever-changing ecosystem we showed the
footage we took to an expert in sea
erosions Sancho a direction of boggling
obstacle nodule it's a geographically
fidgel so it can be eroded it can be
washed because a sandy island orchards
at least two to three beakers to be
permanent without an embankment buzz and
char would be too dangerous for
habitation experts DW contacted
disagreed whether the barrier is high
enough but the government seems adamant
to relocate row hangar to the island
they may port them with that we don't
have enough space here so we will for
them if they are not really will force
them once the decision has been taken
refugees could be relocated in a matter
of weeks even against their will and EWS
Naomi Conrad who filed that report is
with us here in the studio great to see
you now me so what's your impression of
the camp when you were there were you're
not thinking well this is going to be a
lot better for the refugees than Cox's
Bazar where hundreds of thousands are
living in really difficult conditions
well if you look at the settlement
itself yes it's it's an improvement the
people would have more space the rooms
that area the the camps and Cox's Bazar
stiflingly hot in the summer I mean I
went inside some of the hearts it's
really difficult to spend for me to even
just spend half an hour for an interview
inside these hurts so if you look at the
settlement itself yes the infrastructure
is a lot better there's security
the roads are secured but then you have
to look at the island itself and the
questions that you know we try to dance
and the report of whether this island is
actually safe whether the flood
embankment is high enough so the
settlement itself looks a lot better but
the bigger questions around the island
and also whether were the refugees would
be allowed off the island with the they
would have free movement
there's other questions now you spoke
with me on numerous foreign minister
about the relocation plans he suggested
that the revenger could be moved to the
island even if the UN objects let's
listen to what he had to say what is the
most extreme step you could take if the
UN disagrees would you kick the UN
agencies out induce will if that is
necessary will do so to be clear if they
don't support your plan of buzzin shy
you will tell them to we have to make a
decision and we'll talk to them and see
you so it sounds like Bangladesh is
government is absolutely determined to
send the refugees to this island
what is the UN saying about it yes I
mean Bangladesh built this settlement
for the Ringo they spent a lot of money
on it so of course they want to move the
ringer there but it's difficult because
the yearn I mean the agencies they're
footing the bill of this multi-million
dollar humanitarian effort I at Cox's
Bazar so they they depend on
international donors to feed the
refugees to provide schooling for the
refugees to you know provide all the
basic health care all the basic
necessities that the refugees need so it
would be incredibly difficult to to
force the refugees to leave against the
against the the UN's wishes it's a
difficult situation diplomatically very
sensitive at this point apparently a
number of the refugees really are saying
that they do not want to go the island
they are afraid to go there for the
reasons that you mentioned if not enough
volunteers are found among the refugees
how would the government go about
forcing them together
yes it's very difficult to imagine them
sending in tanks or soldiers of course
but what they seem to be doing right now
and that this just came a couple of days
ago is that they want to make the living
conditions or difficult in Cox's Bazar
so we just heard that they've they're
forcing the telecommunications providers
to turn off the internet not to sell SIM
cards to hinga anymore
which would basically cut them off from
any kind of communication so there seems
to be that kind of pressure you know
putting pressure on the refugees to make
the living conditions even harder in
Cox's Bazar which may then lead
a certain number of ringer to maybe sign
up voluntarily to move to this island
which then suddenly looks maybe more
attractive than it does now very quickly
how soon do you think we could see those
refugees moved to the army well in in
Dhaka there was talk of after the
monsoon so in that coming weeks
okay Naomi thank you so much DW
correspondent Naomi Conrad